الفوز التاريخي للاخضر السعودي على
المنتخب الارجنتيني في المونديال ما زال
حديث الكل ويثير ردود الافعال
ثنائيه امام منتخب مرشح لاحراز اللقب جعلت
الصحافه العالميه تفتح قاموس المدح
وتستعمل كلماته للتعبير عن اداء ابهر
الجميع امام رفاق صاحب الكره الذهبيه
السبع انها اللدغه العربيه هكذا عنوانه
صحيفه صان البريطانيه صدر صفحتها الاولى
وتابعت بالقول ميسي يفشل في تحقيق الفوز
ضد السعوديه في احدى مفاجات كاس العالم
حيث خصيره الارجنتين لاول مره في اخر ثلاث
سنوات اما صحيفه الجارديانا البريطانيه
فعلقت الدوسري بطل صدمه زلزال في
المونديال وتبعت السعوديه تصدم الارجنتين
بهدفين متتاليين وتلحق بها الهزيمه صحيفه
ماركه الاسبانيه قنبله ناريه تاريخيه في
وجه الارجنتين فيما كتبت موندو ديبورتيفول
اسبانيا ايضا ضربه قويه للارجنتين امام
السعوديه
اما صحيفه انت البرازيليه فقد وضع تعليقا
طريفا على النتيجه بقولها شكرا للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه جعلتم صباحنا جميلا في
البرازيل شكرا لكم من 200 مليون برازيلي
هي اذا مباراه ستبقى راسخه في اذان
المشجعين السعوديين والعرب وفي كل انحاء
العالم بعد ان كتب الاخضر السعودي بدايته
في المونديال بمداد من ذهب